any man who calls a poison a woman's
weapon is a traitor to his fellow men
a dagger arrow axe these are the arms of
passion but poison is called calculating
poison is the thought that wakes you in
the morning and lulls you to sleep at
night
you watch your victim die a thousand
times before you ever offer him that
fateful taste he's a man's age so
inferior to a woman's that we are to be
denied such a weapon when I was a boy of
sixteen a great Lord caught me with his
mistress he should have been honored
instead the fat old fool challenged me
to a duel thanks to my age and status
only to first blood but his mistress and
his wife warned me which of my parts he
intended to draw first blood from he was
strong and fierce but slow I cut him
quickly and the duel ended with honor
satisfied then his wounds festered and
he died ever since men have called me
the red Viper a name that never fails to
draw a laugh from me as if a single
serpent was all I knew a venom essence
of nightshade is the gentlest of poisons
a drop dissolved into wine will slow a
pounding heart and stop a hand from
shaking three drops will grant a night
of deep and dreamless sleep ten drops
and you will have a sleep that does not
end basilisk blood it will give cooked
meat a savory smell but if eaten it
produces violent madness in beasts as
well as men a mouse will attack a lion
aftertaste of basilisk blood but to a
man who knows his art is not passion a
form of madness
widows blood forces a man's bladder and
bowels to fail he drowns in his own
poisons a slow and painful death it has
earned its name many times I am sure the
tears of lys a rare and costly poison
clear tasteless and odorless dissolved
in wine or water it eats at a man's
bowels he dies in agony which will not
appear unusual if the victim is old or
sickly the favorite tool of impatient
errors across the world on certain
islands of the Jade Sea grows a certain
plant the leaves must be aged and soaked
in a wash of limes sugar water and
certain rare spices from the Summer
Isles afterward the potion must be
thickened with ash and allowed to
crystallize the process is slow and
difficult the necessaries costly and
hard to acquire the alchemists of lys
know the way of it and the faceless men
of Braavos and the maesters dissolved in
wine it makes the muscles of a man's
throat clench tighter than any fist a
victim's face turns as purple as the
little crystal seed from which his death
was grown and so we call it the
strangler which of these files would I
take from its shelf you may ask none to
kill a man at his table or in his bed
bores me to toil hours over a boiling
pot measuring and stirring bores me how
life begins is always entertaining and
my kind must make sure its end is worth
our weight